We are excited to be teaming up
with Dolly Parton Imagination
Library to
introduce you to some wonderful
authors work with us.  Through
the Imagination Library is awe
inspiring.
Across the world.  Here at the
Library of Congress we share
that passion for developing the
young leaders and we know that
past way
to encourage people like you is
to make reading fun.  That's
what we are here to do.
>> Llama llama, red pajama,
feels alone without his momma.
Baby llama wants a drink, but
momma is at the kitchen sink.
Llama llama red pajama, calls
down to
his llama momma momma says she
will be up soon.  Baby llama
hums a tune.
Llama llama red pajama, waiting,
waiting for his momma.  Momma
isn't coming yet.  Baby llama
starts to fret.  Llama llama red
pajama.
Whimpers softly for his momma.
Momma -- hears the phone.
Baby llama starts to moan.
Llama llama red pajama pajama,
listens quiet for his momma.
What is momma llama doing?
Baby llama starts boo-
boo-hoo-ing.
Llama llama red pajama, haulers
loudly
for his momma --.  By ay llama
stops and pouts.
Baby llama jumps and shouts.
Momma momma red pajama in the
dark without his momma.
Eyes wide open, covers drawn,
what is
momma llama is gone?
Momma momma read pajama weeping,
wailing for his momma.
Momma llama, will his momma ever
come?
Momma llama,  run:run!.  She
drops the phone.  Oh, my gosh.
My goodness, is something wrong?
She runs upstairs.
He looks pretty okay.
Baby llama, what a tissy.
Sometimes momma is very busy.
Please stop all of this llama
drama
and be patient for your momma.
Little llama, don't you know?
Llama momma loves you so.  Momma
llama is always near.
Even if she is not right here.
Llama momma red pajama gets two
kisses
from his momma.
Snuggles pillow, soft and deep,
baby llama goes to sleep.
[applause]
Some what was happening with
baby llama?  He was so
frustrated waiting and waiting
for his momma.  He didn't like
waiting, no.
He needs to learn to be patient.
So now we are going to sing a
song about being patient and you
can do it, I know you can.
>> I am patient ♫
I can wait ♫
One, two three, four, five and
six,
seven, eight, nine, ten ♫
I can wait ♫
I am great ♫
One more time
>> I am patient ♫
I can wait ♫
One, two, three, four, five and
six, seven, eight, nine, ten ♫
I can wait ♫
I am great ♫
That's great.  Now we are going
to do a little action rhyme
about going to bed.  It's about
-- we changed it to make it
about llama llama.
We are going to go to bed and
put his hands sleeping -- yeah.
And then he is going wrap
himself in
his covers and then sleep all
night.
And then the morning comes and
he
opens his eyes and off come the
covers
and then he jumps up and is
ready for the day.
Let's do it.
Llama, llama is going to bed.
Down on the pillow he lays his
head.
He  wraps himself in covers
tight and
this is the way he sleeps all
night.  Close your eyes.
Morning comes, he opens his
eyes.
Off with the toss the covers
fly.
Soon he is up and dressed and
away,
ready for fun and play all day.
One more time.
Llama llama is going to bed.
Down on the pillow he lays his
head.
He wraps himself in covers
tight, and
this is the way he sleeps at
night.
Morning comes, he opens his
eyes.
Off with the toss the covers
fly.
Soon he is up dressed and ready
and away.
Ready for fun and play all day.
So now let's do that old nursery
rhyme from mother goose.
Wee Willie winky the tune goes
la, la, la ...
Wee Willie winky,comes through
the town,  uppers and downstairs
in his nightgown.
Knocking at the window, crying
at the lock.
Are all the children in their
beds it's past 8:00.
Wee Willie winky runs through
the town town.
Upstairs and downstairs in his
nightgown.
Knocking at the windows and
crying at the lock.  Are all the
children in their beds?
It's passed 8:00.
[applause]
Okay, now we will read another
book.
>> And now we are going to read
"Llama Llama and the Bully Goat.
"  Also written and illustrated
.  Llama llama, busy day.
Writing, counting, pictures,
clay.
Roll the pancake, draw the sun.
Almost everyone had fun.
Time for circle, time for song,
time
to clap and sing along.
Kitty, rhino, sheep and calf,
llama, Nellie and giraffe all
sings songs in their own way.
Mooo, bello and  bray.
Llama llama claps the beat.
Gilroy goat just points and
bleets.
Sheep goes bahh and cat goes woo
and Gilroy thinks that's silly
too.  Llama llama likes to sing.
Gilroy laughs at everything.
Llama sings out just the same,
Gilroy says a not nice name.
Teacher has some things to say,
calling names is not okay.
Being mean is not allowed, teach
teacher says to stop it now.
Time for  recess.  Go outside.
Monkey bars and slippy slides.
Nellie's dolly makes a road.
Fuzzy llama pulls the load.
Kids climb up and kids climb
down.  Everybody runs around.
Nellie dolly wants to dig.
Fuzzy drives a great big rig.
Gilroy stands in fuzzy's way.
Gilroy, do you want to play?
Gilroy bleats and kicks the
dirt.  He gets sand on llama's
shirt.  Gilroy throws some dirt
at Nellie.
Haha,.  Gilroy pushes, fuzzy
falls.
Haha, llamas play with dolls.
Gilroy snickers, laughs and
kicks.
Gilroy tosses toys and sticks.
Gilroy stomps on llama's coat,
Gilroy
is a bully goat.
Gilroy, this is not okay.
Stop it or we will go away.
Being bullied is no fun.
Walk away and tell someone.
Gilroy fusses, frowns and pouts.
Gilroy gets a long time out.
Teacher says, let's try again.
Gilroy, can you be a friend?  No
more  kicking.  No more names.
Time to play a  nicer game.  End
of recess, back inside.
Gilroy sits by teacher's side.
Everybody sings the song and
this time Gilroy sings along.
Gilroy goat has fun with llama.
But school is over and here
comes momma.  Tomorrow has more
games to try.
See you  then, friends waive,
good-bye!
>> That's a good book. Nice.
Now we are going to sing about
having
good manners and being kind and
caring with our friends,  right?
So this is to I'm a little tea
pot.
La-la-la ...
I have super manners, yes I do,
I can
say please and thank you, too.
When I play with friends I like
to
share, and that's the way to
show I care.
I have super manners, yes, I do.
I can say please and thank you,
too.
When I play with friends I like
to
share, and that's the way I show
I care.
[applause]
>> Now we are going to do an
extended version of that classic
round -- we
won't try a  round, make new
friends.
So the tune goes.
♫[ MUSIC ]♫
La-la-la ...
Make new friends, but keep the
old.
One is silver and the others
gold.
A circle is round, it has no
end,
that's how long I want to be
your friend.
A fire burns bright, it warms
the
heart, we have been friends from
the very start.
You help me, and I'll help you.
And together we will see it
through.
Make new friends, but keep the
old.
One is silver and the other's
gold.
A circle is round, it has no
end.
That's how long I want to be
your friend.
A fire burns bright, it warms
the heart.
We've been friends from the very
start.
You help me, and I will help you
you.
And together we will see it
through.
[applause]
>> Oh, you sound lovely. Now we
are at the end of our story
time.  Thank you so much, Thea.
And let's do our good-bye song
which
is the opposite of our hello.
Good-bye is a simple waive and
then we
will do the friend and it's time
to say good-bye.
Good-bye friends, good-bye
friends,
good-bye friends, it's time to
say good-bye.
Thank you for coming to story
time at Library of Congress.
[applause]
Okay, don't get up.  We are
going to  continue.
Yeah, we've got another.